and now for your eyes only to something
I prepared earlier to the pledge
production team from ambassador Nick
Ferrari assessment on current personnel
as requested attached the only favorable
things that could be said of Michelle do
Bri are inept insecure incompetent
incapable of a coherent position on
anything aside from growing up in East
London June Sarpong is diplomatically
clumsy for a man who has risen to some
of the highest offices in the land Greg
Dyke radiates insecurity media reports
of vicious infighting and chaos between
him and Carole Malone which she
dismisses as fake news are mostly true
Carole is dysfunctional but now while
those candid even brutal appraisals were
in jest well all but one truth
had it been for real I would have
dramatically restricted the note
circulation that's what's impossible to
fathom about the Rao concerning our
outgoing man in Washington so Kim
Derek's view of Donald Trump and his
administration we need candor from our
ambassadors and our consuls I have no
problem with this possibly one-sided
take on events Foreign Affairs Committee
Chairman Tom to geun-hye has said it's
possible these notes might have been
seen by quotes dozens of pairs of eyes
that's where the problem lies
now as for Greg's obsession with Twitter
Big Macs and cheesy fries
[Laughter]
I think you know you're absolutely right
about what was said the tone of that
that's cable was quite abuses I thought
I thought I thought the word it sounded
personal it sounded a bit [ __ ] to me
actually and I think you're right and
and the thing is he's gone now he's
resigned and and he had to go there was
no question because you know we're told
the senior Tory sources would say that
this was to exact revenge over him
failing to promote regs at Britain and
if that was the case well then that is
then it's partly his fault he had to go
if he wasn't doing that now he's that
he's an he's an art you refine that he
was Tony Blair's you were advised
between two seventy two two to seven to
eleven um but but in and I what I've
been here this people are saying it's
stupid to say people who said which was
well no not not by a man who represents
our government in Washington they
haven't and especially on the heels of
the state visit which was supposed to to
to soften trauma
Trump up and indeed but now all that
goodwill has been scalded great day
what's the role of an ambassador Oh to
look after our interests in that
particular country seems a friend to
give sound assessments of governments
and to give sound assessments am i I
loved some of these quotes I mean though
I mean you know think it was a sound
assessment we don't really believe this
administration is going to become
substantially more normal less
dysfunctional less unpredictable less
faction ridden less diplomatically
clumsy and inept I mean you can't get
worse than that and the final one was
when he said that he thought Trump might
survive and emerge from the flames
battered but intact like Arnold
Schwarzenegger in the final scenes of
the Terminator I'm an idiot incredible
language I suspect the phone office
haven't realized what having someone
like Trump as president means that
actually you can't buy this stuff you
can't you you it's because in the New
York Times or The Washington Post every
day they look for journalists it's fine
it's they're not representing anybody
other than their newspaper it's not fine
for you ambassador I don't think in the
world win this
you've run many many businesses you'll
have seemed dis obliging their Mo's
abouts are surely the key is restricted
information that is very very my main
point is while it's not only going to
more about two people that's my main
driving well then if it's only two
people you must go and tell them it
rather than fighting it but the question
is the real question is who leaked it
yes one one gets the feeling no there's
no evidence that it was that the leaking
was political not civil servants yeah
I'll be quick I just want to pick up
something else that was in the memo and
he said there is no upside with this
president in being subtle let alone
ambiguous so perhaps that's what he was
trying to do with his narrative because
what I would say to you is I agree I
think that 100% he should have written
this memo but I actually think it
shouldn't have been circulated at all I
think it should have been filed for
historical purposes because I think we
need to be documenting this moment in
history so all the information is there
for when we look back on it the problem
is like Greg said with somebody like a
trump who is so petty
once something like this comes out the
relationship is done I want to bring
Michelle in Carole I know you want to
but you've been sort of semi glaring at
me I don't think you think they should
ever been committed to print is that
right yeah well I think that in life
when you're considering which job to do
you've got to assess your suitability
for the role so when I looked up in the
dictionary today that's how bored I was
this morning diplomat it says maintain
relations a person who's tactful
skillful in managing difficult scenarios
and people now I would look at that and
think to myself that's not a job for me
if I've got to be diplomatic if I've got
be tactful I'm probably not going to be
putting myself in that position if you
are as sec him did put himself in that
position it's wholly inappropriate to
then be describing people and scenarios
in the language in which he did this is
a man with an extremely extremely
distinguished and long career let's just
say he's a I put it to you I put it to
you that a senior government sources I
want a frank candid assessment of Trump
and his administration's the terminology
unvarnished that's what they asked for
an unvarnished perspective and you
cannot give an unvarnished perspective
without resorting to things like
terminate arising for the ashes it's
embarrassing is unprofessional
he shouldn't communicate like that in
his job and as for the person who did
was clearly tonight come you should
crunch response this is genius I mean if
it wasn't serious stuff it actually be
hilarious so this is what Trump had to
say the wacky ambassador that the UK
foisted upon the United States is not
someone we are thrilled with a very
stupid guy he should speak to his
country and Prime Minister may about
their failed Briggs in negotiation and
not be upset about my criticism of how
badly it was handled I told at Teresa
May
how do you deal with how to do that deal
but she went her own foolish way was
unable to get it done a disaster I don't
know the Ambassador I've been told he's
a pompous fool tell him the USA he now
has the best economy of military
anywhere in the world by far what
Cameron said about people who tweet too
much anyway but anyway you just said
before June that he was petty I don't
believe any president anywhere could
fail to be insulted by that kind of
language and to realize Julian's word on
everybody else it doesn't matter that's
irrelevant when you have when this is a
diplomat I think I think it was
insulting and and the thing is you know
he can no longer do his job he was there
was a piece in one of the papers yeah
today saying he's blaming Boris Johnson
for not supporting him in the debate
you're breaking straw which doesn't
support his Johnson since the breaking
straw was when Donald Trump says we will
no longer do you see the administration
will not do this and he's quite right to
say that you can't have a present here
where we first and faded over him
because we want favors and then tear for
him to be slagged off worldwide but the
president I mean what I mean the idea
that anyone's gonna take Trump's advice
on how to negotiate just because it's
because there's a clown actually he's a
clown with a record employment and the
stairs all-time high this week about if
you had taxation for companies you sure
gonna give up that's not the point he's
you his response to this is the problem
as you say his response to this once
he'd responded like that I grew you did
Boris Johnson throw suckin under a bus
no I don't think he did because the
Kim's position was untenable but for me
I'm glad that he's written this because
we need this documented we need to know
what Britain really Lord of Trump during
this period but I'm not offering any
support on that TV debate do you think
mr. Johnson's rusik him under a bus no I
think that Boris did the only thing that
he could have done and I don't think he
threw him under the bus I think he
answered pragmatically and
professionally no support great I think
he did sorry under the bus so I think he
did so him under the bus he would have
gone anyway so you know he wasn't the
only one fighting him I think he did and
he didn't need to he could have seen he
could I mean historical you've done you
de said of what we've got four
subordinates we've got support about man
and then in September
no I don't think because if one man is
gonna sour relations between between
America and us at this very very
critical time he has to go simple and
Boris would have got rid of the money if
when he becomes Prime Minister and good
night
Trump there's no way Trump would have
accepted Boris waiting you know dealing
with a president like Trump he had to
move swiftly but then that means that we
now allow foreign parties which is after
you know what that's no I don't I'm not
happy
surely there was a choice either as Greg
and I have said you let you let's knock
it into the long grass and you move him
inside him or you promote him Oh Bertie
so you put him at be given a lordship
and just bring him home so he's promoted
yeah but I think he should be phased
behave properly and said he has done the
run we just listen to what am circum
himself has said on there the current
situation is making it impossible for me
to carry out my role as I would like
although my purse ting is not due to end
until the end of this year I believe in
the current circumstances the
responsible course is to allow the
appointment of a new ambassador anyway
you